what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to kanye west gold digger
featuring jamie foxx before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos on this channel i react to red
pill content as well as rap videos and
i'm looking to react to something new
because
i've been getting bored lately so
send me videos to react to
and please subscribe but okay
beware of the gold digger
okay she take my money
well i'm in need
yes she's a triflin
friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you guys see how much more natural
the girls look in this video
like they don't look super photoshopped
or super big
or super like bbl girl
get down
[Music]
gina for lopez four kids and i gotta
take all they back to showbiz okay get
your kids but then they got their
friends i pulled up in the bins they all
got a plan we all went to den and then i
had to pay if you [ __ ] with this girl
then you better be paid you know what
take too much to touch her from what i
heard she got a baby by buster my best
friend said she used to [ __ ] with usher
i don't care what none of y'all say i
still love her and i ain't saying she a
gold digger
i thoroughly enjoy like i don't know
this is
so much
it's weird it's definitely sexual but
it's so much less sexual than like rap
videos i see today
[Music]
get
18 years 18 years she got one of your
kids got you for 18 years this reminds
me of brittany ryder that's like that's
the song
this was the warning to pj washington if
he was born if he was a little bit older
he would have heard this song and been
warned i know somebody paying child
support for one of his kids whose baby
mama concrete is bigger than his you
will see him on tv any given sunday when
a super bowl and drive off in a hyundai
she was supposed to buy your shorty tyco
with your money she went to the doctor
with your money she walking around
looking like michael with your money
should've got that insured guy go for
your money
if you ain't no
[Applause]
[Music]
18 years 18 years and on the 18th
birthday found out it wasn't his
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
like these girls are so much more
attractive to me than the girls you see
in music videos today with the fake bbls
and like like this just looks natural
[Music]
you got knees you don't want to do the
smoke but he came out you go out to eat
he can't pay y'all can't leave his
dishes in the back you gotta roll up his
sleeves but while i watch and watch him
he gonna make it to a benz out of that
toxin he got that ambition baby look at
his eyes this wiki mopping floors next
week is the fries so
stick by his side
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my gosh okay this song i already knew
before before i even started the video
this song
was a five out of five like i just this
song is fire
it slaps now
um
yeah totally
and i just appreciate like i think the
beauty in that video is so much more
natural than the stuff you see today
on the media so let me know in the
comments if you guys like that music
video or not don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell as usual and i will talk to you
guys next time